[Music]
greetings to my 3abn family and welcome
to another 3abn today Bible Q&A my name
is Ricky Carter and I'll be your host
today we've got another hour packed
program with your Bible questions and
you know what we've got the answers from
the word of God and I've got my panel
here who's going to be answering those
questions and let me introduce you to
them to my right we have brother Jason
Bradley Bradley welcome brother thank
you my brother I'm looking forward to
diving into the word of God and and
sharing the answers to the question
questions amen amen next to him we have
my brother Mr morone I can't call myself
to call you by your first name oh no
that's fine since there's two Daniels
here today anyway that's right but I'm
feeling part of the family and thank you
for the invitation all the questions
that people are sending us to thank you
so much for sending your questions and
next to Daniel morone we have another
Daniel Daniel pin welcome brother that's
right glad to be here Daniel the greater
Daniel the Lesser and I just I look
forward to hearing I know some questions
that you guys are answering I'm looking
forward to hearing what their responses
will be what God's responses will be
amen amen wow wow so we've got two
Daniels on the program today so Jason
that leads me to make ask you dare to be
a Daniel dare to stand alone dare to
have a purpose firm dare to make it
known
amen all right well before we get into
our program we want to ask the Lord to
give us wisdom want to pray right now so
brother more
con could you share pray absolutely
Father in Heaven Lord what a privilege
it is to open your word together Lord
and Lord we can have fun studying your
word and you just give us so much truth
in your word that help us to helps us to
live our daily lives by listening to you
your Holy Spirit speaking to us so we're
so thankful for your Holy Spirit
blessing us now and all of those viewers
now in jesus' name amen amen amen
well Jason before I give you your first
question I want to let our viewers know
at home how they can participate well
you can participate in one of three ways
you can email us Bible QA 3abn.org
official says at 3abn official all right
Jason here is your first
question should Christians participate
in acupuncture that's from Christen who
sent it to us texted that to us from
Maryland nice well the short answer is
no Christians should not participate in
acupuncture I would encourage you to
contact our call center uh during non
Sabbath hours at 618 627 465 one and uh
get this booklet what's wrong with
acupuncture there's a lot of great
information in here that will shed more
light than I can in three minutes uh but
acupuncture is an extension of dowst
cosmology and astrology and so let's
consider Deuteronomy 18:
9-14 when thou art come into the land
which the Lord thy God giveth thee Thou
shalt not learn to do after the
Abominations of those Nations
there shall not be found among you
anyone that maketh his son or his
daughter to pass through the
fire or that useth divination or an
observer of times or an enchanter or a
witch or a charmer or a consulter with
familiar spirits or a wizard or a
necromancer for all that do these things
are an Abomination unto the Lord and
because of these Abominations the Lord
thy God doth drive them out from before
the Thou shalt be perfect with the Lord
thy God for these nations which Thou
shalt possess hearkened unto observers
of times and unto diviners but as for
thee the Lord thy God hath not suffered
thee so to do now listen to this quote
from what's wrong with acupuncture page
29 in TCM which stands for traditional
Chinese medicine true health is present
when there's a balance of yin and
yangong remember that yin and yangong
are opposites hot and cold day and night
light and dark good and evil as
Christians we know we should never ever
mix Good and Evil 1 Peter 3:1 says let
him asue evil that word isue means shun
let him asso evil and do good let him
seek peace and insue it Romans 12:9 says
let love be without hypocrisy what
is evil cling to what is good the last
passage I'll leave you with is Matthew
chapter
7: 17- 20 even so every good tree
bringeth forth good fruit but a corrupt
tree bringeth forth evil fruit a good
tree cannot bring forth evil fruit
neither can a corrupt tree bring forth
good fruit every tree that bringeth not
forth good fruit is heun down and cast
Into the Fire wherefore by their fruits
ye shall know them the roots of
acupuncture are in astrology and
spiritism therefore a Christian should
not partake in it and there's a a point
in acupuncture that means Spirit gate
shouldn't shouldn't participate in
acupuncture amen Amen brother Moone
here's your first
question since God's word says he
doesn't strive with mankind always does
that mean a person's probation can end
at any time during his lifetime and that
was texted to us wow well that's a great
question thank you for sending that one
in you know our viewers probably
referring to Genesis CH 6 and verse
three where it says and the Lord said my
spirit shall not always strive with man
for he also is
flesh yet his days shall be 120 years
now this was just before uh the flood so
God is talking to Noah here and so this
word says um my spirit shall not always
strive with man indicates that there is
a stopping point in God's holy spirit
working upon
man so going along with this in Hebrews
chapter 3 and verse 7 and 8 we read
wherefore as the Holy Ghost saith today
if you will hear his voice Harden not
your hearts as in the days of
provocation in the day of Temptation in
the
wilderness this today means now or
present tense we read here where it says
for man to not Harden his heart so it
sounds like man has a role to play where
he can choose either to listen and Obey
or disobey the prompting of the Holy
Spirit where he says he's not always
going to strive so it sounds like we got
a choice whether we want to listen to
the holy spirit so to answer your
question yes our probation can close at
any time during our lifetime so it
behooves us doesn't it to Listen and
Obey it's not an arbitrary Act of God
but it's rather us choosing whether to
harden our heart to God's still small
voice his holy spirit when we do Harden
our hearts it means that there's no
longer a responsiveness from our hearts
to his still Small Voice it's like the
very first time that you hear God speak
to you it might be very convicting but
as you continue to harden our hearts
we'll say we keep pushing it aside ah
I'll get to that or for whatever reason
we take it casually and we don't listen
then pretty soon that voice or that
still small sound that we're hearing
becomes fainter and fainter until
finally we don't even hear it anymore
and that's really dangerous so it's
behooves us to today is the day of
salvation Harden not your hearts amen
amen thank you for that
answer all right brother parin here's
your first
question according to Matthew chapter 6:
19- 21
what are the treasures that are laying
up in heaven and that's from Linux in
Canada that Tech that came to us by a
text all right Linux let's hear the text
here first in The Sermon on the Mount
Matthew chapter
6 therefore do not lay up for yourselves
Treasures on Earth where moth and rust
destroy and where thieves break in and
steal but lay up for yourselves
Treasures in Heaven where moth and rust
do not destroy and where thieves do not
break in and steel for where your
treasure is there your heart will be
also now a treasure that's something
that is of Great Value that we
appreciate and love and there are
Treasures on Earth we think of jewels
and rare coins and money and prosperity
and perhaps beautiful works of art and
we certainly cannot lay those up in
heaven we can't throw them high enough
we can't get them into heaven and God
does not value them the way that we do
Luke 16:15 says this
for what is highly esteemed AB among men
is an abomination in the sight of God
other words God does not see Treasures
the way we do now the Bible does not
forbid us from owning or using Treasures
as God would direct us but but what is
valuable what does God actually value so
what is valuable in heaven well I got to
point out that gold is used as a
construction material and as pavement so
the things we value are not of the same
value there but what is value valuable
is Jesus there's the most valuable thing
and listen to Peter talk about this in 1
Peter 2:7 he says therefore to you who
believe he that's Jesus is precious it's
a valuable word 1 Peter 1:19 but with
the precious blood of Christ we are
redeemed that's that's something of
Great Value and all of this the the two
uses of precious there're referring to
Jesus written by the man who denied
Jesus and he's never going to let go of
someone so precious again
but you cannot store Jesus up in heaven
he's already there what do you put in
heaven well you place in heaven your
life record that's your choices the
record of who you are and that's how we
appear before the Judgment seat of
Christ so listen to Peter use that word
precious one more time in 1 Peter 3: 3
and 4 do not let your adornment be
merely outward arranging the hair
wearing gold or putting on fine apparel
rather let it be the hidden person of
the heart that's your character with The
Incorruptible beauty of a gentle and
quiet Spirit which is very precious or
valuable in the sight of God your
character is what God values so Jesus
values Faith Hebrews 11:6 says without
faith it's impossible to please God he
values Godly love 1 Corinthians 132 and3
uh if I don't have love then I am
nothing without love it profits me
nothing Jesus values knowing him John
17:3 Jesus says and this is eternal life
and that's of Great Value that they may
know you the only true God and your son
Jesus Christ whom you have sent so what
do we do how do we store up Treasures in
Heaven We allow God to transform our
character so we reflect what Jesus is
like amen amen thank you for that answer
brother okay Jason I've got your second
question would you please explain Psalms
chapter
23:5 and that's from Cheryl in Illinois
who texted that to us nice nice thank
you for your questions Cheryl let's look
at Psalm chapter 23 verse5 it says you
prepare a table before me in the
presence of my enemies you anoint my
head with oil my cup runs over so let's
break this verse down into three parts
part number one you prepare a table
before me in the presence of my enemies
now I don't know about you but the last
thing want to do in the presence of my
enemies is sit down and enjoy a full
course meal and I love to eat you
wouldn't believe it I love it but I
wouldn't want to do that uh so I would
be preoccupied with thoughts of them
trying to attack me or cause me harm now
that being said the previous verse says
yay though I walk through the valley of
the shadow of death I will fear no evil
for you are with me when God is with us
we have no reason to be fearful because
our God is faithful amen now this is
definitely a a scripture to hold on to
if we are alive during the time of
trouble and it's a scripture to hold on
to just period um but part number two
you anoint my head with oil it's
important to note that the 23rd psalm
was written by King David and so let's
take a look at his anointing that took
place in 1st Samuel uh chapter 16 veres
1 12 and 13 Verse 1 now the Lord said to
Samuel how long will you mourn for Saul
seeing I have rejected him from reigning
over Israel fill your horn with oil and
go I am sending you to Jesse the
bethlehemite for I have provided myself
a king among his sons verse 12 so he
sent and brought him in now he was ready
with bright eyes and goodlook and the
Lord said arise anoint him for this is
the one and verse
13 then Samuel took the Horn of oil and
anointed him in the midst of his
brothers and the spirit of the Lord Came
Upon David from that day forward so
Samuel arose and went to
Rama now in second
Corinthians 3:1 17 keep the anointing in
your mind uh now the the Lord is the
spirit and where the spirit of the Lord
is there is Liberty in the last days no
matter what trials tribulations or
persecutions we Face may we remember
that we have freedom in Christ because
we have the spirit of the Lord amen part
number three my cup runs over King David
was blessed beyond measure despite his
circumstances are you breathing right
right now your cup runneth over can you
see right now your cup runneth over can
you hear this message your cup runneth
over and so we are blessed beyond
measure and uh our cup runs over amen
amen thank you very much brother for
that answer okay brother morone here's
your second
question how do you glorify God what
does glory mean and that was sent to us
from Alaska wow Alaska thank you for
sending that
question well let's start with a
scripture that speaks of glorifying God
like 1 Corinthians 6:
20 for ye are bought with a price
therefore glorify God in your body and
in your
spirit so here when we look up the Greek
word for glorify which is
oo it means to render or esteem glorious
or give honor to magnify it comes from
the root word DACA meaning
honor
dignity praise and
worship so how do we glorify God in this
text glorify God in your body and in
your spirit is what it says so could we
say that maybe it's by taking care of
our bodies and Spirits like we spoke of
in the previous question regarding
listening to the Holy Spirit he asks us
to do something with our bodies or not
do something with our bodies Maybe by
listening to him that would be bringing
glory to him We're worshiping him we're
showing him honor
Amen in 1 Corinthians
10:21 it says whether therefore he eat
or drink or whatsoever ye do do all to
the glory of God Amen
MH and then you ask what glory is well
in Exodus is what the Bible says that
glory is in Exodus chapter 33 and verse
18 and this was where Moses had gotten a
really close relationship with God and
he'd been in the mountain with him for
40 days not eating or drinking and uh
twice so they were really close and so
he asked in Exodus
33:18 and he Moses said I beseech thee
show me thy Glory so he was you know
curious I guess that's how close they
were so this Hebrew word for Glory which
is kabade kabade it actually means
copious or abundance Splendor and
honorable so here's what God tells Moses
you know show me thy glory and so God
tells us what his glory is I make all my
goodness pass before thee and I'll
proclaim the name or the character of
the Lord before thee and I will be
gracious to whom I will be gracious and
I'll show Mercy on whom I will show
mercy so in this context the glory of
God is his character he's gracious
longsuffering merciful abundant goodness
goodness of God thank you amen amen
thank you very much all right brother
paren here's your second question and
this is your opportunity for a 4-minute
answer can you please help me understand
Romans 9:22 and
23 I know God is merciful and just I
believe that those who will not be saved
would have chosen to reject him but also
in this chapter it says in verse 18 God
has Mercy on whom whom he wants to have
mercy and he hardens and he hardens whom
he wants to harden and that was emailed
to us all right I love to study the book
of Romans and I can tell that you do too
so let's get into this Paul has just set
up the whole found the beautiful
Foundation of Salvation in Romans
chapter 1 to8 but is salvation for
everyone really for everybody well
Romans 9 to 11 those three chapters they
answer this question all all in in one
unit and the main point of those three
chapters 9 to 11 comes near the very end
of chapter 11 chapter 11:32 and so we
got to keep the end in mind all along
the way through we read as we read
through chapter 9 and 10 so Romans 11:32
says for God has committed them all to O
to Disobedience that he might have mercy
on all Al every single person that's
God's goal in everything he does to
extend the offer of Mercy to everybody
so we will read with the end in mind as
we're going along here Romans 9 began
with Paul's deep longing for his
countrymen the Jews who've rejected
Jesus as the Messiah and Paul is
wondering does mercy extend even to them
will will God offer them something
because uh God's chosen people appear to
have tripped over the Messiah as as a
stone in their way and what will God do
for them so Paul asks in verse six have
God's promises failed verse 7 to13 then
gives two examples that being a part of
God's chosen people is not a matter of
genetics you have Abraham's two sons
Isaac and ishma genetically both
belonging to Abraham but only one chosen
then the next Generation Isaac's two
twin Sons born at the same time sharing
the womb together and yet only one of
them was chosen and so belonging to
being chosen by God is Not based upon
our inheritance based upon our genetics
what is it based on and the the
questions the text that you're referring
to fit into this section where it
describes that being chosen by God is
Not based upon our inheritance not based
upon I've got 10 Generations in the
church or look how what I've
accomplished how many Souls I've brought
to the Lord it is based 100% on God's
decision of us that's exactly where it
lies amen and so the main point of these
texts Romans 9:14 to 29 is that God is
free to do as he chooses we cannot
manipulate his sovereignty and we cannot
earn or Force God into doing what he
want what we want him to do remember the
punchline is that God wants to give
Mercy to all and God chooses that what
whatever he does everything that God
does even to Pharaoh even to Moses even
to uh the disobedient Jews is all for
the purpose of extending mercy so verse
14 and 15 you have I will have mercy on
whom I choose that that's written that's
quoted in the context of the golden calf
story in Exodus 32 Israel could not have
earned God's mercy God gave it as his
own choice and his purpose verse 16 to
18 you have the story of pharaoh and it
illustrates that God is Sovereign over
Pharaoh no other person could be in
charge God is Sovereign God hardens the
heart of pharaoh and he does it by the
way by revealing his own character he
Reveals His goodness and then Pharaoh's
the condition of Pharaoh's heart
responds in the hardening uh to what God
has done verse 19 and 20 gives the the
analogy of the Potter borrowed from
Jeremiah 18 the pot can't say to the
maker here's what I'm going to be no the
maker says to the pot here's what you're
going to be and now we're going to read
this text here verse 22 to
24 what if God wanting to show his wrath
and to make his power known endured with
much longsuffering the vessels of Wrath
prepared for Destruction I want to point
out that God is Not preparing them for
Destruction their own decisions have
prepared them for Destruction and so God
is enduring he's longsuffering here
that's what we're seeing in order that
his power will be made known and that he
might make known The Riches of his glory
on the vessels of mercy and who does God
want to have mercy on us everybody
that's all uh that he has prepared
beforehand for Glory even us whom he
called not only of the Jews but also of
the Gentiles both Jews and Gentiles and
so who is it that's excluded from this
offer nobody is God is having
longsuffering on those who deserve to be
destroyed Pharaoh deserved to be be
destroyed but God held him up God
preserved him longer so his power and
mercy could be revealed to anybody who
would accept the offer amen praise God
all right well Jason before I give you
your third question I want to remind our
viewers at home how you can participate
well you can do that one of three ways
you can send us an email to Bible QA 3ab
m.tb that's Bible QA at 3ab M.T secondly
you could text us to 618 22839 975
that's 618 228
3975 and then for those of you who are
on Instagram you can send us your
questions that way as well Instagram at
3abn official so at
3abn official all right Jason here's
your third
question what verses can I use to help
people understand that it's not their
dead loved ones they're seeing but
demons impersonating them and that's
from Sharon in Canada who texted that to
us nice well Sharon uh as always when we
share the word of God we want to share
it from a place of Love U but I would
start by letting them know that God
condemns necromancy which is a form of
Divination in which a person calls upon
the dead to receive communication that
clarifies knowledge now I shared these
verses earlier but they're still
applicable here as well Deuteronomy 18:
verses
10-2 there shall not be found among you
anyone that maketh his son or his
daughter to pass through the fire or
that useth divination or an observer of
times or an enchanter or a witch or a
charmer or a consulter with familiar
spirits or a wizard or a necromancer for
all that do these things are an
Abomination unto the Lord and because of
these abom Nations the Lord thy God doth
drive them out from before thee another
passage I want us to consider is
Ecclesiastes chapter 9: 5 and 6 and and
we're kind of looking at the state of
the dead here because this is very
important for the living know that they
will die but the dead know nothing and
they have no more reward for the memory
of them is forgotten also their love
their ha hatred and their Envy have now
perished never more will they have a
share in anything done under the Sun so
their loved one is not their deceased
loved one is not visiting them it's not
possible that would be a demon um the
next passage I would share would be 1
Thessalonians chap
4: 13 through 17 and I I I believe that
these verses really make things clear as
it pertains to the state of the Dead 1
Thessalonians 4: 13-1 17 but I do not
want you to be ignorant Brethren
concerning those who have fallen asleep
lest you sorrow as others who have no
hope for if we believe that Jesus died
and rose again even so God will bring
with him those who sleep in Jesus amen
for this we say to you by the word of
the Lord that we who are alive and
remain until the coming of the Lord will
by no means precede those who are asleep
for the Lord himself will descend from
heaven with a shout with the voice of an
archangel and with the trumpet of God
and the dead in Christ will rise first
then we who are alive and remain shall
be caught up together with them in the
clouds to meet the Lord in the air and
thus we shall always be with the Lord so
you see from those passages that I just
shared it cannot be a person's deceased
loved one that's visiting them it could
only be a demon and so I would share
those verses with them from a place of
love and in the right timing amen amen
that's important yes okay brother Marone
here is your third question and this is
your opportunity for a 4minute answer
great could you please explain Timothy
5:23 that's was texted to that that was
texted to us all right well let's start
off with 1 Timothy 5: 23 see what it
says says drink no
longer
water but use a little wine for thy
stomach sake and thine often infirmities
I've kind of convicted I've been
drinking this water
here so you know take not only
water as your
drink but take a little wine this is
from the Bible B in basic English this
is another version of that same text do
not take only water as your drink but
take a little wine for the good of your
stomach and because you're frequently
ill so we see that Timothy evidently was
a very conscientious person very strict
it could have been um you know they had
vows you know like if you were a
Nazarite vow then uh you couldn't have
anything from the vine you know
fermented
unfermented raisins grapes anything like
that but for whatever reason it's kind
of interesting too that Paul just
interjects this in this we would say a
paragraph in his reading there it's kind
of you wonder what why did he throw that
in I look at that Paul was quite uh
concerned about his uh young fellow that
was just coming into the
ministry so
uh it says how how much wine you it
tells you a certain amount how much wine
does it
say little wine right it says the word
little and for what reason was he
supposed to take this wine because of
his stomach and then other infirmities
that he had so it sounds like he was
kind of a sickly person Timothy and then
uh Paul like I said he's kind of taking
him under his wing like a fatherly
advice to
Timothy you know and I'm not sure why
the question came but sometimes people
use this one to say well I can drink
look at it says right here in the Bible
take wine that's what a lot of people
use it for I don't know if that was your
reason but
anyway uh do we have evidence in the
Bible I mean in outside sources like of
the early 1 Century this is when this
was happening Paul and Timothy um of
wine being used medicinally and we
actually do have that there's guy named
plyy plyy The Elder he wrote the most
suitable this is a quote from him the
most suitable drink for all men was wine
and this is how he says it with strength
reduced by
filter so if you go and look him up it's
in Natural History
2324 and it says with strength reduced
by filter even explaining the difference
between must which is the part you just
grind up all the seeds and skins and
everything and then fermented wine he
actually shows a
difference and then there's a guy named
plutar and he devotes an entire
discussion to whether wine should be
strained declaring wine cleansed that's
the word he used by strainer has its
strike and Madness taken away so we
think those guys didn't know what they
were doing way back then and we think
we're really smart because Mr Welch
invented grape juice by the way Gra
rures didn't get it into the dictionary
till the late 1800s so leaving I'm going
to finish that quote here has it strike
and Madness taken away leaving one in a
mild healthy state of mind and that's
from
sosc 693 B 3 to 5 and then the B
Babylonian talmud records debates
regarding whether wine should be
filtered on the Sabbath or not and
that's in Shabbat 139b so looking back
you know in history wine and it was used
medically and it was just a little in
fact I just to throw this in I use grape
juice every morning I take just a little
bit of grape juice because it keeps my
uh platelets from sticking together I
learned that from Dr Agatha thrash here
I don't know if some of our viewers
remember her but instead of taking a
baby aspirin take a about 6 ounces of
grape juice and uh it'll keep your
platelets from sticking together throw
that in free of charge thanks for the
question amen thank you very much all
right brother parin here's your third
question what happened to the demons
after the pigs they entered ran down the
hill and died did the demons die if not
where did they go and that's from
Lillian and Marilyn who texted that to
us all right Lillian good question and
the quick answer is that after the
demons had W Havoc by destroying life
they went somewhere else to try to do
the same thing they they try to find
some other way to destroy God's creation
now let's go into a little bit about
about what Freedom uh angels have then
this would be Satan and his evil angels
so Satan and his angels have freedom of
mobility within the bounds that God sets
for them Revelation 12:9 says that they
were cast out of Heaven down to this
Earth so they're comi confined here on
this Earth and while Jesus walked on
this Earth he cast demons out of people
in other words further limiting or
restricting their Mobility so they
cannot just go anywhere that they choose
now there are several texts in the Bible
that tell us that uh the evil angels are
being preserved their lives are being
preserved by God because they don't have
life in themselves God is with withhold
I mean sustaining their life until the
great controversy is completely and
finally over and settled after the
Saints in that thousand years in heaven
have judged the angels we read about
that in 1 Corinthians 6: 2 and 3 so
let's read one of those texts and
there's there several others that talks
about the Angels being preserved until a
judgment second Peter 2:4 says for if
God did not spare the Angels who sinned
but cast them down to Hell and delivered
them into chains of Darkness to be
reserved for judgment in other words
they're being held until a later date
they're still alive Jude 1: 6 and 7 has
that same concept of being reserved
later till judgment so now let's look at
the fate of the Fallen Angels it's not
the fate of Fallen Angels is not tied to
the lives of living creatures because
fallen angels are physical beings
otherwise they could not be consumed to
ashes but they are not in the same
Physical Realm or sphere Dimension that
we are they don't require oxygen to live
and nutrition and and uh and water for
sustenance and so when a living being
dies uh somebody who is possessed by or
being influenced and controlled by a
demon the demon doesn't necessarily die
they don't the evil Angel's fate instead
is tied to the fate of Satan listen to
that fate in Revelation
12:9 the Great Dragon was cast out that
Serpent of old called the devil and
Satan who deceives the whole world he
was cast to the Earth and his angels
were cast out with him so their fate is
tied together so what is that fate
Matthew 25:41 says then he will say he
will also say to those on his left hand
depart from me you cursed into the
Everlasting fire prepared for the devil
and his angels all right and that's
together so this is something prepared
for both of them together one more text
for the fate of the of Satan and his
angels Revelation 20:10 the devil who
deceived them was cast into the Lake of
Fire and Brimstone where the Beast and
the false prophet are and they will be
tormented day and night forever and ever
referring to until completed uh no break
until it is finally completed after this
sin is completely 100% gone that's the
event where Satan and his angels are
finally uh done away with so what
happens in the meantime Matthew 12 43:
and 44 says when an unclean Spirit goes
out of a man or is cast out he goes
through Dry places seeking rest and
finds none here it is they're continuing
on looking for a spot where they can
influence then he says I'll return to
the house from which I came and when he
comes he finds it empty swept and put in
order in other words uh the demons here
cast out of and gone into the pigs and
when the Pigs die they have their
limited mobility and freedom and they're
going out looking for somebody else to
influence so that's what happened to the
demons M thank you thank you very much
for that that answer all right Jason
here here's your fourth question and
this is your opportunity for a 4-minute
answer
beautiful has the weekly Sabbath ever
changed and I was texted to us okay well
no God never changed the weekly Sabbath
to Sunday the Bible doesn't State
anywhere that the weekly Sabbath has
been changed from Saturday to Sunday but
let's look at some verses to gain some
clarity on the matter Daniel 7: 25 and
here uh Daniel's speaking of the the
papacy here um he shall speak pompous
words against the most high shall
persecute the Saints of the most high
and shall intend to change times and law
what what law God's law what's God's law
The Ten
Commandments then the Saints shall be
given into his hand for a time and times
and half a time now we know in his that
Constantine the Great um attempted to
change the Sabbath from Saturday to
Sunday in 3:21 ad I believe it was in
March but don't quote me on that we'll
go ahead and Google that look it up um
but once again God never changed the
Sabbath perhaps you've heard the phrase
it was written in stone or it is written
in stone well the Ten Commandments were
written in stone signifying their
permanence amen now something worth
noting is that the fourth Commandment is
the only Commandment that begins with
the word remember yet it is most often
the one that is forgotten the most uh
Exodus chap 28 20 verses 8- 11 says
remember the Sabbath day to keep it holy
six days you shall labor and do all your
work but the seventh day is the Sabbath
of the Lord your God in it you shall do
no work you nor nor your son nor your
daughter nor your male servant nor your
female servant nor your cattle nor your
stranger who is within your gates for in
six days the Lord made the heavens and
the Earth the sea and all that is in
them and rested the seventh day what did
God do he rested the seventh day
therefore the Lord blessed the Sabbath
day and hallowed it now nowhere in the
Bible does it say God blessed the first
day of the week and hallowed it it says
he blessed the Sabbath day which we know
as the seventh day and hallowed it we
see the seventh day Sabbath all
throughout the Bible in Genesis 2:2
we'll go back to the
beginning and on the seventh day God
ended his work which he had done and he
rested on the seventh day from all his
work which he had done now I've heard
people say I'm a new testament Christian
well in the New Testament Jesus observed
the Sabbath and so did his followers
Luke 4:4 through
16 then Jesus returned in the power of
the spirit to Galilee and news of him
went out through all the surrounding
region and he taught in their synagogues
being glorified by all so he came to
Nazareth where he had been brought up
and as his custom was he went into the
synagogue when on the Sabbath day and
stood up to read another thing to
consider is that even in Christ death
burial and Resurrection he rested on the
Sabbath the seventh day Sabbath and Rose
on the first day Sunday Luke
23:
54-56 say that day was the preparation
and the Sabbath Drew near and the women
who had come with him From Galilee
followed after and they observed the
tomb and how his body was laid then they
returned and prepared spices and
fragrant oils and they rested on the
Sabbath according to the Commandment
Luke 24: 1-3 says now on the first day
of the week very early in the morning
they and certain other women with them
came to the tomb bringing the spices
which they had prepared but they found
the stone rolled away from the tomb then
they went went in and did not find the
body of the Lord Jesus and I leave you
with this Jesus said if you love me keep
my Commandments amen amen thank you very
much brother okay brother morone here's
your fourth
question how did the Bible get
canonized who decided which scriptures
to
include when was it done and that's from
James in Oregon who texted that to us
well thank you James that's a good
question you know it takes more than a
three minute
answer but I I'll give you the three
minute version and for those that don't
know what canonized means the word Canon
actually it's a Greek word and it's just
got a K in it otherwise it looks pretty
much like our English word Canon and it
means to rule or like do you remember we
used to have little rulers in school I
don't know or a measuring stick so
basically it was the decision of people
to what uh came up to par to put into
the this Bible here so that's what
canonization so documents from the 4th
Century show that different councils
within the church released lists to
guide how various Christian texts should
be treated the earliest known attempt to
create a canon in the same respect as
the New Testament was in the 2
century was Rome it happened in Rome
with a guy named Maron he was a Turkish
businessman and he was a church leader
so marcion's work focused on the Gospel
of Luke and the letters of Paul so that
was the first canonization or attempt to
bring things together so disapproving of
this effort the Roman Church expelled
marcian we don't like this and you're
out of here so the second century Syrian
named taan he attempted to create a
cannon by weaving the four
gospels at uh together um and it was
called that
dieron and then there was another one
called meritoria Canon that was believed
to a date back to 200 ad and it's the
earliest compilation of the canonical
text that resemble our new testament
that we
have and it wasn't until the fifth
century that all the different Christian
churches came to a basic agreement on
the biblical Canon the books that
eventually were considered Canon reflect
the times in which they were
embraced but during the Protestant
Reformation in the 16th century books
not originally uh in Hebrew like this as
far as the Old Testament part they were
they were written in Greek such as
Judith and
macbes they were excluded from the Old
Testament
and these are known as the Apocrypha
today and they're still included in the
Catholic Bible I don't know if that's a
good enough answer but but anyway that's
thank you so much for the question but
it's a lot deeper than that even but a
lot of arguments back and forth whether
things should be and shouldn't be and
some people wonder how come the
Apocrypha books didn't get into the
Bible we have it was the uh Bible
Society there was a paper shortage and U
most people didn't agree with those
anyway so they just didn't put them in
the Bibles that and now that's the way
they are
today thank you thank you very much sir
all right well brother parin I have your
fourth and final
question is there a Bible passage that
supports the quote you cannot give what
you don't have that's from Joseph in
Arizona who emailed that to us all right
thank you Joseph the answer is yes there
is and I've got 10 here we'll see how
many I can go through but I've used that
that that statement and I've heard that
statement referring to sharing your
faith or sharing your testimony you can
only share what you have so let's look
at a few of those Job chapter 14 verse4
who can bring a clean thing out of an
unclean no one in other words you can't
give a clean thing if you don't have
cleanness Matthew 7:18 a good tree
cannot bear bad fruit nor can a bad tree
bear good fruit you can only give the
kind of fruit that you have the fruit
that is in you because that's what you
got Luke 6: 45 a good man out of the
good Treasure of his heart brings forth
good and an evil man out of the evil
Treasure of his far heart brings forth
evil for out of the abundance of the
heart his mouth speaks in other words
what you have inside you is going to be
what comes out every single time now you
can try to fake it for a while but
ultimately what's inside physically and
spiritually is what comes out James chap
3: 11 and 12 does a spring send forth
fresh water and bitter from the same
opening can a fig tree my brethren bear
olives or a grape fine bear figs thus no
spring yields both salt water and fresh
the water that comes out is the same
water that is inside it's not mixed with
something else only what's inside can
come out acts 3: 6 Peter said oh you
like this one silver and gold I do not
have but what I do have I give to you in
the name of Jesus Christ of Nazareth
rise up and walk Peter says I can't give
you what I don't have I have no money
I'm gonna give you what I do have and he
says I know the power of Jesus I give
them Luke chapter 9 verse 13 uh but this
is one of jesus' Parables where a man uh
no this is not a parable sorry Jesus
looks at his disciples when the people
are hungry and he says you give them
something to eat and they said all we
have is Five Loaves and two fish es
unless we go buy food for all these
people and so his disciples illustrate
to him we can only give them food that
we actually have and this this is all
that we have and Jesus is teaching them
of course a lesson that he has the
Abundant Supply if they will go to him
and the same is true for us if we go to
Jesus spend time with him our supply
will be increased what meager little
that we have now can be multiplied in
the presence and the power of Jesus
let's do a couple more here Luke 11: 5 5
to8 and he said to them and this is that
Parable which of you shall have a friend
and go to him at Mid at midnight and say
to him friend lend me three loaves for a
friend of mine has come to me on his
journey and I have nothing to set before
him I can't give him what I don't have
so I got to go get it from somebody else
in this case Jesus is talking about
prayer come to me persistant because you
don't have what you need to share with
others come to me all right uh three
more Matthew 25:8 and the foolish said
to the wise another Parable give us some
of your oil the foolish have no oil they
don't go to the other ones who have no
oil because they don't have oil to give
they go to those who do have oil give us
from your Surplus well none of us have a
surplus of the Holy Spirit it doesn't
belong to us anyway that's what the oil
represents here all right uh 2
Corinthians 8:12 speaking about giving
Paul writes for if there is first a
willing mind mind it is accepted
according to what one has not according
to what one does not have all right so
God doesn't require us to give what we
don't have all we can give is ourselves
and that's what we do have and we see
this Illustrated in Leviticus 5: 7 and
11 for the sin offering you were to
bring a lamb well if you didn't have a
lamb you couldn't give a lamb and so you
could give a pigeon or a two turtle
doves well what if you didn't have a
pigeon or two turtle doves verse 11 says
you could give an offering a small
amount of flour so God says it doesn't
matter what you have you have something
to give God gives you what you can give
to others amen amen amen thank you thank
you for that well hope you've been
blessed by all those answers I know I've
been we're going to take a short break
and we're right back so don't go away
and oh check out this great site 3abn
Bible anwers.com but hey we'll be right
back if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible
Q&A then tell your friends each Monday
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand to have your questions
answered on a future program just email
them to us at bible QA
[Music]
3abn.org
975 that's 618 228
3975 be sure to include your name and
where you live and then watch 3ab Bible
Q&A for answers from God's word thanks
for coming back well we're almost out of
time but before we go want to get some
final thoughts from our panelists
brother Jason yes uh I just want to say
thank you thank you so much for
submitting your questions and uh it's
been a a an honor and a a privilege to
open the word of God and study this out
you know I look at the Bible as basic
instructions before leaving Earth and
this is a a rich treasure chest with
gems that we need for everyday life so I
want to encourage you to continue to
study God's word and please continue to
send in your questions so that we can go
to the word of God and we can break
bread with you amen Amen brother Mar
con yes I I too want to thank you for
sending in those questions I really
enjoyed that one about the wine thing to
and did a really deep study I had never
done that before so I learned a lot of
things about that that I didn't realize
that they could actually do for at last
a year to make unfermented wine way back
and of course like I said wine was just
the word was used for any type of a
grape juice or fermented or unfermented
and the actual grape juice didn't come
in until after Mr Welch figured out
after Louie Pastor you know keeping
germs from getting into the u u bat okay
so thank you again amen amen well I just
wanted to go back to Romans chapter n
for just a moment and in the context of
Romans 9 I want to share Exodus chapter
9 verse1 15 and 16 it's the the seventh
plague the plague of hail and Moses
speaking on behalf of God says if I had
stretched out my hand and struck you and
your people with pestilence then you
would have been cut off from the Earth
God says I could have destroyed you
already but indeed for this purpose I
have raised you up and the Hebrew word
really deals with I have maintained you
held you up that my power shown may be
shown in you and my name declared to the
end of the Earth God's goal is to keep
people up so that his power can be
displayed amen amen thanks for joining
us I'll leave with with this fun
scripture song There Is therefore now no
condemnation for those who are in Christ
Jesus who do not walk according to the
flesh but according to the spirit Romans
8 verse 1 God
[Music]
bless